active cleansers like sabium germason  active are a great way to simplify your  skincare routine it targets excess oil  and dead skin cells which contribute to  clogged pores in oily acne prone skin  cell silica and glycolic acids work as  chemical exfoliants that loosen dead  skin cells refining and smoothing the  skin's surface zinc gluconate is also  included to reduce shine this cleanser  uses a gentle non-ionic surfactant to  effectively remove dirt and excess oil  without being too aggressive the foam  rinses off easily and it's packed with  humectants so it isn't drying so this  cleanses your skin effectively and acts  on clogged pores while respecting your  skin's natural protective barrier